aronia wins a game
that frankly he looked like he was lost
most of the way but magnus carlsen
missing one key trick and all of a
sudden it's only three and a half one
and a half
carlsen going for the berlin endgame
end game he does play regularly
but that stylistically i believe should
suit leonardo who also has a lot of
experience here
as well goes for bishop g5 which i think
is not the main move here
threatening rook d8 checkmate
parried by magnus because we should be
six
i don't know d2 for baroque d1 looks
logical there are also plans with knight
e2 and knight f4 was knight e2 bishop d5
i think that's a theoretical line
yeah knight e2 plate
d5 plate
no yeah there were different moves now
f4 i have t4
ft4 plate
takes takes
river bolt is saying this guy's voice is
the asmr i need thank you riverbolt
i love being called this guy
rook d2 plate
this is a weird position black obviously
can't castle anymore since this king
has already moved and then went back to
e8
white wants to
just crash very directly if black were
to stabilize
he'd be he'd be okay very often i'm not
sure if directly
you're even okay exchanging bishops here
with the black pieces which looks a bit
strange
because you would think the two bishops
are your big trump compensating for the
double pawn the king in the center
that's really more about getting squares
for your pieces and the light square
bishop itself
is usually enough of a match for the
knight
so i wouldn't be surprised if councilman
bishop e7 here or bishop b4 c3 we should
be 78 he goes bishop v7
just trying to create some squares for
his pieces
88
yeah no getting a lot of asmr comments
today
the truth is chet
i'm having a cold and trying to
stop sneezing and coughing all the time
so i'm you know
curbing
my excitement i don't think i usually
talk like this
still i'm glad you enjoy it
point h4
i know it always feels like
white should be better but if you switch
on
computers here and most chess players
even myself
have spent a lot of time staring at
computers in these berlin end games they
will usually tell you that black is okay
flexor boy is saying you usually kinda
talk like this when you feel sarcastic
can you even feel sarcastic
i don't know i'm not doing it on purpose
if i'm bringing the king still looks
much better for white
but once again
as long as these pawns don't start
rolling on the king's side
it does seem
that
the current school of thought is that
all these end games are just just fine
take stakes there are no entry squares
for the rook
i know it's rook i'm working on it
92.
do you go c5 do you activate your own
rook
i don't know
that
basque
anyway those are beautiful words max
australia
see
we ask sanfermi to be our guide
that he will
guide us in the
sounds like locked up
giving us his blessing
deep
for the end game
still take white
still think
should be equal but
if anybody's better it has to be white
here comes knight
the examiner is saying is he i'm drunk
it's never
an opportunity
see
i'm not even making any sense
i was going to say there's never an
opportunity to get drunk so which makes
zero sense
sure
there's plenty alcoholic beverages
live on making some progress here rook
d4 rookie four
the black pawns also had to go a4 b5
making much harder
to keep advancing
looks like yeah he's on the verge of
breaking through
which would mean if you were to win this
that's three and a half two and a half
so all to play for
not over yet
but progress has
certainly been made
here comes the king
this looks very hard to defend
zen b is saying young things drawing
arrows equals commentary then my beloved
and
chat
i was so happy to see you again do a bit
of english commentary
this what i'm getting
c6
giving up this square this might be
the final nail
in his coffin we wanted to put the
bishop on d5
but it allowed white's knight some fresh
jumps
and apparently
there's no way back
puff daddy in the family knight takes
his six king g4
going for counter play with king g3
but is it enough kg6 king g3
knight e5 aromian organizing his pieces
now it's question of counting f7
takes takes
the repeat moves once
is this winning f7
take take
king g2 knight g5
h3 knight h3 would be winning
so i don't see why not knight g5 king g3
i don't get to me it looks winning we'll
see
or romeo taking his time
shouldn't overdo
the thinking part here
carson also down to seconds
assume is calculating if f7 is a win or
not
it goes knight g6 back we've had this
before
f7 and takes on h4 ah that's what he's
been calculating
king e7 also winning f7 and the x just
counted
and yeah he wins this game three and a
half two and a half everything looked
like smooth
sailing for magnus carlsen but now he
loses